ladies and gentlemen it's a special
episode of stevo's wild ride today
because you know this guy was my hero
when i was a kid
and i'm telling you right now he's no
less of a hero to me
today because just check this
out ladies and gentlemen tommy lee
dude yeah what's up all right we're all
packed into the van but everybody's been
tested for coronavirus
yes that's right uh i actually got um
accepted for the convalescent uh
plasma program because you have the
antibodies because i tested positive for
the antibodies
it's crazy right steve steve has the
antibodies
so he's had it before so that's way good
the crazy thing is i i tour with them
i'm his tour manager
i'm with them oh yeah this is scott i'm
scott it's there paul's up front
what up paul yo yo what's up tommy
[Laughter]
he's got a mic yeah oh yeah all right
so the crazy thing is i'm with steve 24
7. if i'm not with him he's editing with
paul and if he's not with us or
at the same time he's with his girl and
none of us have the antibodies
none of us had corona we're trying to
figure out how that's even possible
wow i'm just not a germaphobe you know
yeah me either
neither my wife's got me like [ __ ]
she follows me around with
that i think that that's more unhealthy
than anything probably
skin's all dry because it's alcohol like
i don't know
whatever yeah okay so dude i mean where
to even begin it's just like
i've been i've for my whole life milked
this story about how i [ __ ] met you
guys when i was a kid i was such a
die-hard motley crew fan
and uh it is a good [ __ ] story i mean
it's pretty
[ __ ] about out that's when you
reached out to the call to different
hotels yeah i mean dude i was
such a [ __ ] motley crew fan right i
mean like
i had like nothing but motley crue on my
walls
you know that whole theater paint era
was was uh
i had everything like i've like the
teachers in school were
over it because every art project it was
a [ __ ] fun
it was a motley crew logo it was a
[ __ ] stuff that was just like all
right enough with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] they were like
woodshop making drumsticks
and uh so yeah when they came to town i
was like dude i found out that they were
there i saw on the news they were there
before the the day before the concert
and i'm like [ __ ] man that means they're
here in a hotel
so i just looked in my albums and found
out the name of their manager and just
started calling every hotel in the
yellow pages
who thinks of that like i just to me i
in my mind i'm like
dude that guy wins because who would
think of reading the
actual liner notes on a record and go oh
there's the [ __ ]
manager maybe they're under his name or
the it's the group the whole
right yeah the same person doing art
projects for school on motley crue
yeah i guess so man [ __ ] hey but
anyone who would that would
decipher that at that age like that's
that's some next level [ __ ] how old are
you
i should work for the [ __ ] cia bro
yeah yeah sure
really i was 13 at the time and uh it's
really cool that you say who would think
that because i can totally tell you
where the concept came from i was
uh like big into like little league
baseball and [ __ ] i was a super baseball
fan and
and i lived in england but every summer
i would come over to the states and
during the summer part of the
like going to the states for the summer
wherever we went my dad would
uh want to take me to a major league
baseball game and he would plan
to we're let's say we were in boston he
would make sure that we were
staying at the same hotel as the
visiting team
of the uh you know so i could hang out
in the lobby and like get autographs
from uh
from baseball players so this is a
genetic thing
yeah totally a little bit yeah and and
when i was sitting there calling the
hotels [ __ ] for hours my mom was just
pissed because back then there was no
car waiting even
it wasn't even call waiting
you're tying up the house phone for
hours over here
and i'm like mom i'm calling motley crue
you know
and like my dad only ever wanted me to
show initiative to
be like passionate to [ __ ] dad was
like
stoked it was like my son this is what
he's [ __ ] on fire right now
so my dad called off my mom honey he's
calling motley crue
what city where were you living at the
time in toronto toronto
yeah in toronto that's crazy and and
dude like this was the girls girls girls
tour
so it was 1987. the concert i went to
was
october 25th of 1987. i did all the
call-in hotels on october 24th
in the picture do you can see the the
backstage pass tapes to my [ __ ]
shirt it says 10 25. that's okay okay
so he's cheating do you even remember i
remember toronto
at that time that that that show i
remember meeting him for sure
really for sure yeah because yeah he's
just like oh cool
no because our tour manager well not our
tour manager our manager's brother and
hit us up beforehand he's like hey man
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] crazy kid
called me in
in my room and told me that he's [ __ ]
literally called every single hotel in
toronto
looking for us and he's a massive fan
and like and uh so i'm gonna i told him
i'd bring him back to say hey to you
guys so um
so i knew about it that's great but then
when we
met um i remember meeting him because he
was
like he is now um nothing's changed hey
dude
the [ __ ] dude [ __ ] yeah
um but uh you know [ __ ]
the picture of services every once in a
while i see it and i still [ __ ]
i get a big smile when he's like 14
yeah for sure yeah i think you were 14.
i was 13 13
18 yeah and and he was like 17.
yeah i know right that's crazy too right
i mean
you were actually 17 when motley crue
formed yes yeah and and you were
considerably younger than the other guys
yeah for sure like yeah right what's
cool about you is you grew up in
covina yeah i grew up in pasadena so get
out of here it's rare to see people that
like grew up here that that make it here
oh my god yeah so did you ever go to the
wood sound
in pasadena uh van halen started there
yeah well my my mom went to school with
van halen
oh [ __ ] passed into high school that's
right
you know they'd always be at backyard
parties with them and wow everybody
you know has that story that grew up in
pasadena but i think my mom was like
two or three years older how old are you
i'm 37. okay that
that makes some sense and where was the
wood sound the wood sand
was it's actually right next to pasadena
uh arcadia
yeah so it's not really right in was it
a bar
it was like a like a yeah what a trip
man that's my small world is that where
you were born
i was born in pasadena at the huntington
hospital wow
so mountain now molly crew formed in
and i forget if it was january or
february the actual date
but dude i've never told the story i
told tommy the other day
a [ __ ] when uh when
motley crue had the sixth anniversary of
their formation as a band
i was such a this is before i met them
at the concert i was such a [ __ ] fan
that like i sent in a [ __ ] creepy
letter to their fan mail all cut out
from the like they'll cut out the
letters of the magazines and glued it
onto a page like a serial killer
yeah i don't even know why i did that
but [ __ ] like happy
sixth anniversary with two x's and six
like nikki sixx
and if i can send it in like to make
sure it was there on time i stole a
bottle of wine from my parents
wine cellar to get drunk [ __ ] to
consider motley crue to honor motley
crew and celebrate their anniversary
so that day i came home from school i
[ __ ] pounded this whole bottle of
wine
and like dude i barfed i didn't i
barfed in the toilet didn't flush it i
[ __ ] my parents had a breathalyzer i
blew it and it [ __ ] left it on the
counter the phone was off the hook
i'm passed out in my [ __ ] clothes
like in the afternoon
like just on top of my bed covers and uh
my my dad
came home he knew the wine was missing
and he's like oh okay so we gotta talk
and uh and he wakes me up to have this
talk with me
but he wants to be kind of cool about it
so we played a game of pool
and i kicked his ass and pulled drunk
why did your parents have a breathalyzer
yeah it was just like a gag
gift that they had gotten for uh for
like
[ __ ] because they were they were they
partied dude
they partied as did motley crue
yeah and you [ __ ] mania
dude that was the first time i ever got
drunk like on my own deliberately
but yeah so the red wine or white wine
it was red
right red wine you didn't flush the
toilet because
i was just drunk dude you got to check
that out
yeah he's like proud of it yeah i'm
saving it for a while
and like so with the start of motley
crew
like 1981 you guys recorded the first
album it was too fast for love and you
did that on your own record label yep
leather records yup and then like you
you got enough buzz around you guys in
the hollywood scene
like the sunset strip you guys really
built this sunset strip
like the whiskey and go-go with [ __ ]
like the all this legendary stuff going
on
you got you created enough buzz that you
signed to a major record label which was
elektra
yeah and then they i just what you uh
like they licensed it you sold it to
them like then they put out
too fast for love yep but still at that
point when two best for love came out on
electra
you guys in really had really blown up
right it was a shout of the devil where
you guys just [ __ ] took over the
world that's where [ __ ] [ __ ] went
bananas man we
that's when uh [ __ ] we got
we got uh the opportunity to open up for
aussies
the [ __ ] bark at the moon tour so now
you know we went from playing you know
400 seat
whiskey go go style shows clubs
to playing in front of 15 000 people
every [ __ ] night and it just
it was that that's when that's when the
[ __ ] [ __ ] just blew up plus this was
right when
mtv came mtv
i think mtv started in like 82. but
they're big
they're big things that came out was
michael jackson's thriller that video
[ __ ] blew up mtv yep playing and
barking at the moon dude
they like meticulously put every hair to
turn
ozzy into a werewolf and the park at the
moon was like this huge budget [ __ ]
thing
and and then and motley career i mean
[ __ ] dude looks that kill video like
that mtv was a big part of you guys for
sure for sure
yeah and [ __ ] i think the home sweet
home video
like i don't know they used to run like
a you'd call in and vote or whatever
and like home sweet home held like the
number one slot for like [ __ ] months
dude we're like dude give somebody else
a chance like
that's so rad but [ __ ] forever like
i it was the longest running number one
was requested requested like
yeah i was pretty nuts man that was some
good [ __ ] dude
did you at the time have like did you
process that at all or were you guys
just kind of
going or were you sitting around like
guys this is crazy
[ __ ] i don't think we even knew what the
[ __ ] was happening we were just like
that's rad
just riding away you know when you're
like i don't know when you're
if we were green as [ __ ] we didn't but
it's crazy we would just be stoked
you know i was like oh my god that's
[ __ ] crazy it's on all the time
yeah wow yeah because i mean you guys
were probably just as stoked doing 400
than to doing 15
000 like you didn't know what was
happening no we had no idea we're just
basically
[ __ ] a bunch of kids just hanging on
and just like [ __ ] whoa dude this is
this is
doing all way more than we thought just
hanging out for dear life
yeah like just enjoying the [ __ ] out of
it was there a moment where you're like
guys we're like
rock stars we did it
you can't be more of a rock star than
tommy lee but boy did i try over the
weekend i did something
really messed up okay it wasn't even
necessarily legal
to have somebody inject into my spinal
cavity
and anesthesia which rendered my lower
half
completely paralyzed while i was
sprinting
and then we did all kinds of gnarly
stuff now why do i mention that
because i dare say i looked really good
why because i am on top of my fitness
and my sleep and my recovery with
this incredible band on my wrist
called whoop it is my whoop strap
it connects to my whoop app
which gives me incredible insight into
my
activities my workouts my sleep
my recovery and dude i
need sleep here last night getting 100
of your sleep needed means you did
everything in your power to perform well
today
that's the kind of news i want to hear
man my recovery
super strong my heart rate variability
totally strong man this thing just keeps
me
on top of what's going on with me and i
love it
plus i never have to take it off because
the charger slides right on top of
the device boom charging
so man i love my whoop strap and i want
you guys
all to try it out so you go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p
dot-com use the promo code stevo
and you get 15 off at checkout again
15 off at checkout if you go to woop.com
and use the promo code stevo you're
going to thank me for
it now back to tommy lee yeah when did
it hit you that you're like this is
[ __ ]
massive i guess you know what when
[ __ ] people start
you know and people start [ __ ] you
know
hating on you like the pmrc yeah like
when as soon as you
that's exactly it dude as soon as
[ __ ]
like you know you're you're pissing
somebody off you know you're doing
something right right yeah
so right when that happens or when you
start getting recognized in public
or you know you start to realize oh whoa
man shit's different
this is very different people are asking
for you to tattoo their name on them
yeah you're like dude no no i was like
dude are you sure
that you want motley crew or or my name
or whatever it is
think about the fast fast forward like
when you're like 75 or 80 are you still
going to be like [ __ ] yeah
if yes then go nuts yeah i don't like
i don't like people getting my name or
my face tattooed over there
that's strange yeah people will say like
oh do you tattoo your
autograph on me and i go nah you don't
want my autograph let me tattoo your
name on your butt like i have it yeah
yeah my butt cheek says your name that
way it's kind of like signature stevo
but like it's kind of funny too it's
more
worth it yeah but uh uh dude so
like you were 17 when when motley crue
formed so then that was like 81
two years later you're only 19 years old
when you're opening for ozzy and [ __ ]
playing arenas and
and like holy [ __ ] shout out the devil
yeah i mentioned the pmrc which was the
parents music
resource center there was like in the
1980s
a concerted [ __ ] effort to like
censor it was a real first first
amendment issue like like wait a second
these [ __ ]
heavy metal bands are satanists
you know the original album title for
shout out the devil and that's the album
that blew up motley crew
it was originally called shout with the
devil
which was like pro satan like come on
we're [ __ ] on satan's team
shout with them join satan's club and
that was like okay there was
the blowback came back from i guess
electoral records they were like yo dude
you can't call
a shower yeah and so they said okay
we'll call it shout at the devil
implying that we're somehow like angry
at the devil and we'll say like
whoever it is that [ __ ] you know
represents evil to you man if it's your
[ __ ]
if it's your boss if it's the cops
i don't know probably probably
nikki's you know nikki was like it's
pretty smart you know like let's just
make this like about like shouting at
any sort of like resistance any
opposition
anybody's [ __ ] with you don't take it
you shout at the devil
shout at the devil
yeah and it was just genius because like
there was this climate
at the time that was just so like they
called it the satanic
panic and like there was the whole thing
with ozzy on his first album he had a
song called suicide solution
which was clearly about alcohol like
like in chemistry a solution is a liquid
and all this song was saying is that
alcohol is just a slow way of killing
yourself
but some [ __ ] kid was listening to
ozzy's record had it on the record
player with his headphones on
and [ __ ] shot his brains out the kid
committed suicide
and they found his body with his
headphones on connected to the [ __ ]
record player and the [ __ ] record
player says ozzy osbourne
suicide solution so there was this huge
lawsuit against ozzie
and [ __ ] he walks in he's like you
[ __ ] dummies
it's about alcohol and they're like oh
okay cool dismissed
[ __ ] crazy man that what was that
your sophomore year book report on
motley crap
dude yeah dude and like twisted sister d
snyder was a big part of that thing but
like hey you guys just i mean
you make such a good point that it's
when people start [ __ ] complaining
when you're pissing them off
that's when you're doing well because
all of this [ __ ]
trying to censor miley crew being mad at
the [ __ ] like the more you piss
people off the
better you do yeah that's that's
that's a fact just more publicity yeah
yeah for sure
yeah and and these guys like i mean
everybody
everybody's seen the dirt on netflix and
congratulations for how
phenomenally successful that was
you know like but it's so hard you know
like i i talk to people fans and [ __ ]
all the time right
and i i've talked to a bunch of young
people that were like
pretty much globally the meaning of a
lot of the emails communications have
been like
dude like you don't even understand like
[ __ ] i wish like i'm so bummed i wasn't
around
to to experience that [ __ ] it must have
been insane
and that's pretty much the consensus of
most people they're like
it really took him back to the way it
was which was
[ __ ] insane fourth gear
popping wheelies [ __ ] till the wheels
fall off
just running it yeah you know you've
already
[ __ ] been a part of that and just
with
you know no instagram pre [ __ ] cell
phone cameras right
we got away with [ __ ] straight
murder
i mean you know and [ __ ] it's
not like that now you you it's so
not like that so for to for jeff did
such a great job and he was like
he told us this as um we were meeting
with different directors and jeff is
like
dude there's you know nicki and i are
meeting with different guys and goes
dudes there's only one guy that can
direct this movie and it's [ __ ] me
hey i'm a [ __ ] fan and i swear to god
i promise you
i will [ __ ] i will i will make
everybody
i'm gonna take everybody right back to
that [ __ ] time of exactly how it was
it's easy and and like in every detail
from the phones to the
to the settings to the wardrobe to the
um i want to bring people back to that
time
and experience what the [ __ ] that was
like you know
and he [ __ ] murdered it well what was
that scene like for you
watching that for the first time when
when your character in there just did a
day in the life and it was just [ __ ]
empty
that was so so fun and so [ __ ] real
dude machine gun kelly [ __ ] murdered
it that guy yeah yeah he did great
yeah he was so it was so funny i've
known that guy for
for a couple years right and he he calls
me up he goes dude
you're not gonna believe this i'm like
what he goes dude i'm
[ __ ] playing you in the movie i was
like what
you know what it were a lot of like like
same kind of flame and [ __ ]
for sure hyper and [ __ ] you know
whatever
and so i was like no [ __ ] way because
we
we got updated uh once in a while on who
who was getting cast and whatever but
i never saw his name come through i
didn't even know he was
so he goes dude i got the [ __ ] script
i'm coming over
i'm gonna [ __ ] make you proud i want
to know exactly
what the [ __ ] every line i want to know
if what went down
if it didn't go down like that how did
it go down i want to [ __ ] nail this
and so he came over we spent a couple of
days
going through the script and then he
went out and took like four months of
drum lessons yeah learning the spinnings
and all the [ __ ] that i do
all my what do you call those in
twirling
just into
i can't even speak intricacies yeah yeah
yeah just my mannerisms that's what
yeah when i played and dude i was like
it was so [ __ ] bizarre like i've
never seen somebody that
dedicated to nailing something he's like
i want to know this i want to know that
don't take the lessons like and i'm i'm
gonna [ __ ]
i'm gonna i'm gonna murder this dude
this is so killer
and then on his tour like you know he's
a [ __ ] like
a a rapper yeah yeah but every night on
his tour
his drummer and the drummer and michigan
kelly would switch spots
yeah so and then so that they could do
play the actual title track shout at the
devil yeah
play that song and [ __ ] there's mgk
every night [ __ ]
drumming away playing shout out to the
devil and it was just
incredible dude that's so rad but and i
think
it's uh rooks his drummer is the is the
guy who
spent the time with him for several
months just showing them hey this is how
to do this this this
pretty wild man talented and talented
kid yeah now
so when i was at the little kid and at
the concert
in in toronto right this was the tour uh
girls girls girls tour
1987. the [ __ ] tommy lee has his his
drum
solo where the drum riser comes up
like in the air like pushes out over the
crowd
and then rotates upside down this had
never been [ __ ] done
but it i mean nothing like nobody even
this was just like wait what
it had to have been so expensive that it
really like cut into the profitability
of the tour
totally on top of the on top of the
[ __ ] private jet they had like
a [ __ ] like motley crew like
747 some whatever some big old [ __ ]
boeing
airplane with motley crew painted on the
side
they flew [ __ ] while they're on the
[ __ ] airplanes they've got
uh flight attendants literally walking
down the aisles
with platters that just have lines of
[ __ ] cocaine serving they're there
totally totally and then this is what
happened to my experience because i'll
never [ __ ] forget it right
like during the concert they're getting
ready to do the the
tommy lee drum solo and this is like you
know everybody knows
it was a genius too because drum souls
were
an obligatory part of every concert and
it was like oh
the [ __ ] drums people go get beers
and buy a shirt take a piece whatever
right all right listen you know that too
oh yeah right it's like with the [ __ ]
drum solo all right so tommy was like
genius to be like hey let's make the
drum
solo like an actual [ __ ] a must-see
like cool thing that people are stoked
for and sure enough they're stoked for
it but then on top of this is how motley
crew does it
like in vince neil he says you want to
have a drink with the crew toronto
[ __ ] like everything yeah we [ __ ]
we want to have a drink with my likes
nikki sixx comes walking out with a
[ __ ] big like a fifth yeah
you call it like the big square bottle
of jack daniels he [ __ ]
unscrews it he like pours him on the
crowd so that the people can tell it's
real you know
yeah and [ __ ] he's like all right he
says it's not iced tea
right and he and nicky sticks just like
[ __ ] cheers he raises the bottle up
to the crowd
and [ __ ] and and he just lifts it up
and [ __ ]
dead like puts an episode and still
chugging it but he they time it so
each gulp that nikki six takes tommy's
on the job
you know like he's like [ __ ] it's
like like you know
boom boom he hits the drums on each gulp
gold and nikki six just straight pounds
half a [ __ ] bottle of jack daniels
and then gives it to [ __ ] tommy
[ __ ] tommy chugs the rest of it
there's no way you can drink that much
jack daniels without being [ __ ]
slobbering drunk
yeah like yeah and this is like halfway
through the show
so like the rest of the show from that
point out was like
[ __ ] dude i'm [ __ ] panicking right
and then and and
tommy's got [ __ ] uh his his
his drum tech stage hands [ __ ]
filling up beer bottle caps with cocaine
yeah to [ __ ] like not like a key bump
you know you put literally a little bit
on that key
a whole bottle cap for a beer filled
with cocaine in the [ __ ] to keep them
going for the rest of the show
i just i just i'd be playing and i would
just lean back like this
the crowd couldn't see it and just still
playing
yeah there we go yeah i heard a story
one time that uh
guns and roses guns and roses open for
you guys and they try to party with you
and you guys drank them under the table
and you went out and did their set
dude be warned ladies and gentlemen
because
tommy lee is about to drop some bombs
and you know what
when i'm dropping a certain kind of bomb
like a big
sloppy dump i like to make sure my butt
holes
real clean and that's why my favorite
product this podcast has ever introduced
me to
comes from hellotushy.com
what is it it's a big day and how does
that work
well when i get done dumping
i got a little knob mounted onto my
toilet
and i give it a twist and it sends a
stream of
water blasting straight into my [ __ ]
and it's so powerful no poo
is gonna last through that and then when
i get done blasting it
i grab a little bit of toilet paper just
to dry off my butthole
and then look at it and be satisfied to
know that there was no poo
left to wipe i mean think about this
guys
let's say you were covered in poo like
you just
got out of a porta potty that got shot
through the sky
and now you're covered in poop are you
gonna take a paper towel to wipe it off
no you're probably gonna want a hose
maybe even a shower
so why should your butthole be any
different take care of that thing people
get yourself a bidet from hellotushy.com
and you know what go to hellotushy.com
stevo and get yourself ten
percent off your order again that's ten
percent off your order
if you go to hellotushy.com
stevo to get one of these genius devices
which again and i've only ever said this
about one product and it's
hellotushy.com it is my favorite thing i
have
ever promoted on this podcast sorry
everybody else
and your butthole is gonna thank me so
back to tommy lee no we didn't do their
set
um uh they did try to
out drink us and we were like oh [ __ ]
here we go again another band trying to
[ __ ]
keep up with us this isn't going to
happen so
we we went at it oh my god we went at it
right and
this slash will tell you this to this
day [ __ ]
we're like then they're just sitting
there slash and duff
and me and nikki were just [ __ ]
pounding shots at the bars like a
there's a day off at a hotel and they're
like
then you could clearly tell it was like
okay we're gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna out [ __ ] party you guys
and we're like all right
so we just [ __ ] keep going keep going
[ __ ] all of a sudden we're sitting
there and slash is starting to get
[ __ ] shitty
and he's just right at the bar at the
bar just right in between him and
duff just like
this blows chunks and he's like okay i'm
back
he's [ __ ] getting he's getting rid of
it anyway he
we keep going we keep going we keep
going [ __ ] it seems like a million
shots later
he's he does one of these on the [ __ ]
bar
[Music]
and we go ah this is [ __ ] great
[ __ ]
we nikki and i grab him we take him
[ __ ] carry him up to his room his
hotel room keys in his pocket
get it out open his room [ __ ] lay him
down
on on the bed face up right [ __ ]
uh uh we remember polaroid cameras
yeah yeah [ __ ] dude we went and grabbed
our polaroid camera
and nikki goes [ __ ] dude get a picture
of this
nikki jumps up on the bed pulls his
pants down
and puts nikki puts his balls
right like right on right on slash's
chin
right there and i [ __ ] rip a polaroid
and the next
day that was his um uh our our
head of security went up and cut off his
[ __ ] uh
laminate uh all-access artist pass
and gave him the new one and the picture
the picture id
was him it's him with mickey's balls on
his [ __ ] shin
i think we've made posters and put him
up everywhere that'll change a man dude
he's like
that'll [ __ ] teach you to think
you're gonna [ __ ] out party us dude
oh my god that was it
i'm sure people tried that all the time
all the time dude and you have probably
a thousand stories of just [ __ ] with
people
we're like [ __ ] amateur hour come on
you ain't gonna keep up with us there
was some there was something like myth
story although pantera oh yeah those
dudes would [ __ ]
they'd run it they keep up oh yeah yeah
meth will do that
for days
so there was this legendary story i
don't know if it was true or not but
like that
some like chasing down the sunset strip
some physical altercation between motley
crue
and danzig and the misfits or something
there oh i don't
that was a backstage incident
i think [ __ ] i don't know what to do
you guys were known for brawling yeah
right
is there like how true is the uh like in
the in the dirt movie
it was like your first show at the oh
and and there's like some kind of just
broke out into a brawl that's a true
story i think that's
that's the oil patch in [ __ ] like
calgary or some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] place like that were just
it was a full-on like
it was one of those places where
everybody was [ __ ] like
bikers or oil riggers or something that
and they're there's four dudes looking
like [ __ ] homos
and [ __ ] in [ __ ] makeup you know
with [ __ ] crazy hair up there playing
[ __ ] livewire and they're just like
what is this book
bag and [ __ ] you know and and
[ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] would happen all
the time and
and and vince and nicky especially
because they're right up front they not
wouldn't think twice about [ __ ] you
know
diving in or vince [ __ ] clubbing
somebody with his [ __ ] mic
stand or nicky with the bass um i'm
behind the drum so it'd be a little
later when i
joined when i joined in if they went in
and go in for backup but
for the most part yeah all the time or
somebody you're sitting there [ __ ]
playing
and somebody's just going and just
spitting on you the whole [ __ ] time
and
nikki he'd take about [ __ ] a minute
of that and be like you know what
[ __ ] you and then the [ __ ] show would
be all over the [ __ ]
smashing people in the [ __ ] pit yeah
i mean it must have happened a lot like
people
didn't think that you guys would fight
back too because of the way you looked
or whatever
yeah oh [ __ ] you guys are weird i loved
[ __ ] scrapping man this [ __ ] was so
fun
jack daniels and cocaine dude yeah
that'll do it
it's crazy how like the the
the 80s represented like just this
this [ __ ] glam hair metal
like dudes wearing makeup like chicks
but they could kick your ass right right
you guys like started that whole deal
right i mean
they before as far as bands wearing
makeup before motley career was
like there was kiss of course but that
was more like clown [ __ ]
yes then then like glam metal like new
york dolls
was one that we we dug uh-huh
baby number of bands that just came
became flowing in to try to
completely copy motley crue a million
right behind us we were like what the
[ __ ] is going on guys
get your own [ __ ] and that's that's a
compliment though
for sure to be emulated and or
you know to do another version of that
you know i get that i get that and i'm
i'm [ __ ] that's that's flattering and
[ __ ] but
you know at some point we were like guys
come on you gotta [ __ ] change it up
uh a lot more you don't do the exact
same thing
slightly different poison went like a
little overboard trying to copy motley
crew because like on their [ __ ] album
their first album
like they actually looked really hot
like a little too much i was like you
know i shouldn't be actually like
like legitimately attracted to my rock
star heroes
his eyes just coming they look really
hot
somewhere else right now yeah i mean
like molly crew they were like okay
you know like they they felt like it was
a good balance of like yeah we're
[ __ ] wild dude this whole deal but
yeah you know yeah and and not all the
best
looking of guys either like the point
like cece
and [ __ ] and brett were like the [ __ ]
they look like chicks
yeah you know so i understand your
fascination
yeah i remember i i shoplifted that
poison album i [ __ ] stole it
yeah dude yeah that's awesome
yeah but dude tommy said something
before about
uh you know he talks with the fans you
know like he's
like interactive with the fans and dude
fully legit dude
like this is i'm so stoked on this
how like when uh you know when i when i
moved out to
to la it was 2001. you know and in
hindsight
it seemed like the [ __ ] era of glam
metal was so
like far in the passage history but
really like it was
you know more recent at that point than
you know i mean
i've been out here for 20 years now you
know i just wanted to [ __ ] party like
motley crue that was my whole
mission in life from the first time when
i heard about motley crue
i i wanted a [ __ ] party like motley
crue
and uh and and and and i i i didn't
waste any [ __ ] time man i mean i was
i lived right on the sunset strip
like i could i lived like [ __ ]
spitting distance from the seventh veil
which they [ __ ] sing about in the
girls girls girls song like i mean dude
it was just all about
living and partying like motley crew and
like i was so out of control
i ended up [ __ ] uh getting uh
arrested on on multiple felonies facing
eight years in prison
and uh and and i'm [ __ ] they told me
i'm not allowed to
like go to the strip club you know i
called crazy girls in my office
every night and they're like no you
can't be seen in the strip club it's
going to be bad optics
you know like you can't do any drugs
because they might drug test you and
that's going to [ __ ] really screw you
so you have to like like be be [ __ ]
under the radar and not on drugs and
trying to tell
that to me at that time oh dude i'm
[ __ ] not okay
i'm not okay with you i was 26 i think
maybe 27 27
and uh and i'm [ __ ] like losing my
mind i'm [ __ ] holed up in my
apartment i'm [ __ ] losing my mind and
i'm like dude
i go i go on tommy lee's website and i'm
[ __ ]
he had a message board and i was just
like just told the story yo dude
[ __ ] i met you when i was a little
kid and [ __ ] i'm in all this trouble
right now i'm facing eight years in
prison but maybe you've seen
[ __ ] our [ __ ] on mtv i'm just
reaching out
[ __ ] like i left my email on there
the next day i got a [ __ ] email it
says tommy lee here
yo dude you're in almost as much trouble
as i've been in
you know i'm like [ __ ] right on dude
like uh god got your back and we just
like became bros you know like
i would be careful not to like you know
bug him with [ __ ] like an annoying
[ __ ] you know like i wouldn't he
wouldn't hear from me if i
if i reached out to tommy it would be
because i had something that was pretty
[ __ ] like
pretty cool pretty [ __ ] entertaining
whatever you know but like just not
not like a pain in the ass and uh
dude so we would be in touch like when i
got arrested
for the international drug smuggling i
was i remember emailing him yo tommy
dude i [ __ ] swallowed this package of
drugs to smuggle it
to another country and it got stuck in
my throat and i'm [ __ ] think i might
die
i think i don't like it yeah and uh and
tommy was brought back he's like is it
poop soup yet
you know something like that we had this
sort of we'd be in touch every once in a
while and then all of a sudden dude
2004 and i don't know if you if you know
this
but in in the same [ __ ] i opened up
my email
i found out there are two two emails i
got at the same
time i remember i was in florida with my
family this is a cr
incredible [ __ ] memory oh dude he'll
be like
he'll be like it was amazing he's been
as a [ __ ] maniac in the
house dude this is the most exciting
there were two [ __ ] emails i found
that day one of them was from my
business manager
and it said yo dude you're [ __ ] being
sued
and he's like i don't want to be
alarmist but you're either going to lose
like a [ __ ] lot or [ __ ]
everything you know like straight up and
it's been going on and you don't even
know about it like you got served
in absentia because like i had these
shady representatives that didn't want
me to even know about it
you know like and they're like get ready
you're gonna [ __ ] lose everything
that was when i just found that out
and then the other email i opened up at
the same exact time was from tommy lee
it says yo dude [ __ ] call me right
now dude his [ __ ]
my house number and so i'm like [ __ ]
all bummed out because i just found out
i'm getting my ass suit off
hey tom yeah and i caught and i but then
i called tommy
and and he says dude okay i got back
together
with motley crue i've been rehearsing
for the last week and we're [ __ ]
announcing we're going on [ __ ] tour
the carnival sends to her like uh
i want you to get on stage and do
something right you remember that dude
yeah totally do something super [ __ ]
up and introduce us oh dude
you have to you have to and it was like
dude it was the most like needed
like morale boost because i was so
bummed man i was just like there it goes
my whole life's going out the window
right now and
the [ __ ] your biggest dream just came
true to open the [ __ ] up
circle and that was 2004. dude that what
a trip that was
[ __ ] crazy man it's like it's really
crazy to [ __ ]
to think about you know that whole full
circle thing like
from from meeting him and then seeing
you know when also just watching his
life
yeah thought through all the [ __ ]
madness as i'm doing mine
he's doing his and just going like and
he's still [ __ ] he's still [ __ ]
alive hey yeah i did i i pitched myself
on a daily basis
um and [ __ ] and doing [ __ ] amazing
and it's it's really cool it's really
cool
yeah you know it really is [ __ ] right
on man let's not squander the time i
always get in trouble because i'm
[ __ ] telling stories about me
and [ __ ] i've got these great guests
we got it we got them
like you guys well i'm interested to
know because we've had this conversation
before too and it's like uh
you know steve used to do the poo condom
or the uh
to smuggle weed you know across state
lines yeah what are some of the clever
ways that like maybe you guys
used to transport drugs internationally
if you can talk about that
uh yeah sorry to throw on the spot there
i'm just curious about like you know
put it up in your nut sack to get
through tsa or i mean what
yeah i wouldn't i'd never put it like in
or on my body
i say in um always um
two places come to mind real quick um
going through whether it's
in the air or on the ground on the
ground if you're on your tour bus
um they have very much like stevo's got
here
on on this truck and in the back
you'd pop it up just by hand it was like
it's
almost like an emergency exit it it
doesn't doubles as a
an emergency exit and for ventilation
so we'd [ __ ] be oh [ __ ] we're getting
to the border
[ __ ] roll over the windows blow the
smoke out i'll [ __ ] make sure
everything's cool
and grab whatever [ __ ] drugs we have
and pop that thing open but you you
couldn't do it like going down the road
fast
[ __ ] would fly off the bus so as soon as
we stop and pull into immigrations
or customs or whatever that [ __ ] pop the
top
nice and slow take the [ __ ]
everything
put it up on the roof of the bus and
close the [ __ ]
that close the ventilation [ __ ] dogs
immigrations dudes you know uh come
through the bus
all right all good see you guys later
and as soon as the [ __ ]
bus door shut boom pop that up pull it
in yeah
that would have been great in the movie
yeah i know and then
you know then i think of the airplane
same same deal
uh like the headliner here you know you
know they're like in an airplane
they've got you know that you got your
headline or upholstery your private
plane
yeah okay
yeah so it would take take [ __ ]
cocaine
whatever it was do as much as we could
before we get there
um whatever was left we'd stick
like i felt above my seat for some
reason there was a
little [ __ ] rip in the headliner so
we'd [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] bag of blow and just
really crank it down
as little really good and [ __ ] just
like
to kind of you know get it up inside the
headline or kind of put it back
it was like a little little p little
like uh
like a little piece of double sided like
double stick tape and just
and you couldn't even tell it's just
like this and then it's in the headliner
same thing
dogs and i'm sitting there dude [ __ ]
poo poo in my pants just like oh my god
just geeked out
just freaked out that the dog's gonna
[ __ ] come stop
and then jump on my lap and then [ __ ]
right never
the dog i don't know it's too high or
or or i don't know but we pulled that
off several times and
never got busted can you imagine though
that that's what was [ __ ] my pants
could you imagine getting busted with a
[ __ ]
ton of cocaine [ __ ] singapore going
to dude
certain places will [ __ ] yeah you
just lock you up forever
you know there's no like oh you know
it's
a fine in a couple years yeah you have
to sign that thing before you get into
singapore saying i
the death penalty if i bring drugs into
this yeah yeah i think bali's like that
too
there's some places where they don't
[ __ ] play around
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah i
mean you've been have you been arrested
overseas
uh they've been pretty clean japan japan
yeah
japan nikki and i got arrested for
throwing [ __ ]
jack bottles across the bullet train hit
didn't hit anybody but smashed it
smashed up on the
on the thing where the doors are and the
you know the station thing whatever
tells you where you're at
shattered and whiskey and glass
everywhere
on a couple people and they called the
cops so at the next stop it was
what did they call you and nikki the the
disastrous
duo oh the toxic
that's pretty cool yeah always getting
[ __ ] in trouble again
another thing that drove me nuts too was
uh i i i read that
um or heard that you gave away your
first gold album that you're doing like
gakers on
yeah dude did do you ever get that back
or did [ __ ] from the publicity you
got from that podcast did somebody reach
out be like dude i have it
you know what i wish somebody would and
and i wouldn't want it back because i'd
it was you know it's meant to but your
first gold album dude
yeah my very f i do not have my first
gold record
and i i know it it's scratched up and
[ __ ] up from
chopping up so much [ __ ] gak on and
i'm
i was high i was like [ __ ] bro i want
you to have it man
[Laughter]
no no it's like no dude i can't it's
your [ __ ] golden album i'm like
[ __ ] that you nap you have it bro you
know when you're [ __ ] high
yeah and i [ __ ] gave it away and i
don't remember to who
was one of those where i was like okay
maybe one day someone would be like dude
i
have it right and like but i don't want
it back but let me know if somebody's
got it that'd be rad to know
dude when we filmed uh the jackass movie
the first movie that you know um the
scene where
where we were in the hummer going
through the desert and they're [ __ ]
tattooing the
the off-road tattoo yeah it was henry
rollins in the movie
but it was supposed to be mickey
supposed to be nikki sixx
and i mean like they told me it was
gonna be nikki six
right and so i show up for that shoot
we're in the desert wherever we're gonna
film this
[ __ ] thing right and i'm sitting
there just like every other day on that
goddamn movie
just do and [ __ ] blow except on this
day i've got
my framed picture of me as a little kid
with nikki sixx and i'm just [ __ ]
working the lines off of it
like as if as if nicki's gonna be really
impressed by
dude that totally sober already at that
point
like yeah cool [ __ ] kook
but uh then uh but then they were like
oh there's your hero nikki six [ __ ]
and and they went up to
they sent me to them and rollins got out
and i thought that roland's gonna beat
me up because oh dude
yeah because yeah he's very well and on
top of that i i've
been uh hooking up with this chick that
always flew out to be with rollins
and like so she told me about like all
these like crazy rolling stories you
know and then i'm on howard stern's been
talking
i've been brought the chick on howard
stern and was like bringing up rollins
you know like so like in that row that
had already all happened
at the point when like they go go up to
the suv and roll it's gonna so i thought
the bit was
that the problems was gonna beat me up
in the movie you know oh my god
yeah he was just super cool yeah did he
even mention
like he did okay nothing professional
and then when my book came out
uh and my book came out the the writer
like did an interview with rollins and
rollins said that he just didn't even
[ __ ] hadn't even ever heard about it
you know
good answer dude yeah right
when in doubt deny it sure but speaking
of books
tommy had his book tommyland and i got
to write my own little mini chapter
telling my story about meeting them as a
kid oh wow and i [ __ ] barged up to
his book signing and just [ __ ] showed
up with like a [ __ ] cooler full of
liquor and [ __ ]
tons of [ __ ] booze i remember my
[ __ ] manager
at the time going like [ __ ] stevo's here
there goes tommy i've lost him like
and as soon as we're together the whole
thing just was like
all right let's go we just [ __ ] we
just
basically just then you had jimmy kimmel
and you guys i got you all loaded for
jimmy kimmel we busted up your dressing
room
yes yeah that was a blast [ __ ] busted
the [ __ ] out of it the
tables chair yeah destroyed [ __ ]
kimmel's dressing room
and then [ __ ] stephen
[ __ ] we can't go anywhere together ever
and uh and then when my book came out
[ __ ] tommy and nikki
gave me quotes for the cover yeah the
perfect book
for the person who hates reading well i
was like you know when somebody asks you
to write a [ __ ] quote for their
for their book like you're not going to
[ __ ] read
a book like in the [ __ ] time you know
like you know i need to be like
like oh yeah like whoever's gonna say
that oh yeah let me let me read the
whole give me a few
days yeah let me read the whole book and
then i'll think about it and
i'm like no dude i was like yo tommy
dude i got this book and like is it cool
if i
[ __ ] write on the cover this is the
perfect book for people who hate reading
and say it to your quote
wow that's hilarious this is the best
i thought that was a great corporate for
uh for tommy dude
killer killer i couldn't have come up
with
yeah i mean my book does read like a
[ __ ] you know
story on tmz kind of it's just like
juicy [ __ ]
well that's those are the best to read
[ __ ] there's nothing worse than
well i was 16 and i grew up in like
no one cares what [ __ ] up [ __ ] have
you done
you know i mean talk to me it was crazy
too because your book tommyland and i
wanted to say that came out in 2004
yeah and uh you didn't you didn't know
that you didn't know that uh
you didn't know that motley crue is
getting back together and you know you
had
you had some [ __ ] to say in that book i
know yeah which is something which is
even saying something because it came on
the heels of the dirt which is
the book that the the netflix motley
crew movie was made out of
and what the what the movie didn't even
attempt to
to like convey was how this book
the motley crew book was written
i mean i don't think a book's ever been
written like that you've got four
members of my life
you got four members of motley crue and
they each
separately took turns writing chapters
you know like doing the other recorded
interviews with the author yeah and the
author
pro just search the first chapter is
like okay
we're reading nikki six in nikki six's
voice but then the thing is
the way they did it like halfway through
the [ __ ] book
they got done with those interviews they
wrote that much and then
they did the [ __ ] back half of the
interviews after each dude read all the
other guys [ __ ]
yeah so then now it's like oh what the
[ __ ] and he says this and his [ __ ]
chatbot i'm gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] he doesn't [ __ ] remember
yeah
it started there was like it was it
brought in this like pretty [ __ ]
like incredible element of like retorts
and [ __ ]
you know like responses like [ __ ] you
like you you know
and it was all like uh i mean dude that
book came out
in 2001 and that was when i very first
was on my very first ever tour jackass
was brand new
i'm [ __ ] god that my motley crew the
dirt i referred to that [ __ ] book as
the bible
it was like it was the [ __ ] gold
standard of what [ __ ]
my lifestyle was supposed to be you know
that's why i had [ __ ] i'm reading
that book
blowing lines off of it [ __ ] yeah i
think i held up the book and called it
the bible on mtv cribs
you probably did because some dude came
came
up to me dude i'm in the middle of
nowhere i'm
a french polynesian island bora bora
there's [ __ ] middle of nowhere and
i'm
and there's kind of nobody there i'm
sitting there and
out of my peripheral vision i see some
dude walking up
real fast you know you can you can tell
you're like oh someone's coming up you
could use this no yeah i can feel it and
i look
a little closer pretending not to and i
see he's got like a book and he's
walking
i'm like [ __ ] he's headed right over
here out of nowhere
and he does he comes over and he's like
dude
[ __ ] bro i'm so sorry i would never
[ __ ] bother you
i'm sure you're on vacation dude but
[ __ ] i'm on my honeymoon and i
[ __ ] i looked out and i saw that you
that was you and would you sign my book
and
he had the dirt and i was like you
brought this on your honeymoon
i go dude you [ __ ] rule he goes dude
and he said this is my [ __ ] bible bro
yeah
so maybe he got that from you because i
was like who brings the dirt on their
honeymoon
i'm like they're probably doing some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah that's a fun
honeymoon
but remember i texted you a [ __ ]
our buddy photoshopped an image of the
actual pope
holding up the bible he's photoshopped
him with [ __ ]
dirt oh my god
so dude when uh and and still you know
so i'm here the other night right like i
did um i did
his wife brittany's podcast right after
[ __ ] hanging out on brittany's
podcast
i mentioned the book conversations with
god just like as
we just got onto some spirituality tip
and like
then when we finish recording the
podcast britney says
oh you know hey you know tommy stevo
talked about this book i don't even know
why she brought it up
and you said that you read the one and
two
conversations of god one and two i was
like yeah dude i [ __ ]
read that guy's books i wrote to him
from jail
he wrote me back um what's his name
neil donald walsh we both met scott and
i both met yeah you met him there yeah
i've dude
we got to chicago that's so rad because
[ __ ] those books moved me man dude it
changed my life forever yeah
that was so crazy to hear tommy be like
yo i read those when i was in jail
so he responded to you while you were in
jail yep did you know who you were
uh i don't you know i don't know if he
i don't i don't think he did yeah maybe
cano cause [ __ ] is on the [ __ ] news
yeah
probably you know i'm assuming maybe but
yeah so when i got you know every week
you'd get your mail in jail like
and i was like no [ __ ] way dude he
wrote me back
yeah yeah go ahead it's just it's just
so crazy man like
i [ __ ] we love that that guy so much
you know i mean he's a polarizing dude
but conversations with god
it just speaks to me and i was so
psyched to hear you say that it spoke to
you
and so when i finished like the the
trilogy whatever i read and finished
reading book three and it was like
at the very end of the book it's like yo
you know get a hold of me come see me
where i'm at on my website
so i finished the book i went on the
website and i'll find you i found out
yeah
this is nothing right sure hey so i i
found him on the web the website and
he's got this little [ __ ] schedule of
like speaking
engagements and and i said oh dude there
he's going to be in chicago
i said scott [ __ ] we're flying to
chicago to go meet
neil donald walsh dude and uh
it just so happened that we booked the
trip we're going to chicago and [ __ ]
in chicago that weekend
is a ufc pay-per-view event so
so i reached out to dana white i'm like
yo daniel dude i'm going to be
you know dana white gives us front row
tickets yes
and so good boy we meet neil donald
walsh and i'm like hey dude this is kind
of weird but is it weird that i'm going
from a
conversation with god conference
yeah what did neil say to you he's like
steve god damn it steve
yeah i was like uh because of your books
i don't i i say gosh
darn it i don't say goddammit you know
like because he didn't you know like
how to respect and he goes god damn it
don't take everything so seriously
oh you gotta love that he sounds like a
wonderful dude man yeah dude he's rad
man
i'll bet i'll bet anybody who's in tune
like
who's in tune like that man and and and
is willing to share that with people you
have any other books that changed your
life like that
um he said he read 45 books
45. it's the most i've ever read in my
entire life in five months
i've i think i just sped read like the
whole
uh there's there's some other ones um oh
lord there's a few there's a uh
female author i ivana
ivan the tinkle i want to suck your dick
oh dude that reminds me of something
[ __ ] happening
i love ivana uh that dude that reminds
me of
something [ __ ] epic uh i remember
when i was in in jaylen sweden i read
the vampire book by anne rice or
whatever i think but but that's got
nothing to do with it
i remember when i went but anyway with
that the first time that we talked about
calling up hotels
i was like you know when we were we were
hanging out and i was like yeah well
like i didn't expect that you would
check in under your real name
and you said [ __ ] uh
you said no dude i wouldn't check into
hotels under my name
i would check into uh [ __ ] what was
it
you said that you had a fake name that
you would check into hotels with called
like
something coxy enormous or dixie norma's
oh yeah dixon
yeah or yeah dick's enormous
peter peter goes in yeah
oh my god what a [ __ ] so much fun
dude doing
the alias just coming up with [ __ ] up
names and i
my mom god bless her uh uh
she is really [ __ ] greek i mean
greek greek and she'd be like and you
know i
she i would give her my hotel alias
because she'd call this is me before
[ __ ] his cell phone crazy yeah she'd
actually call the hotel
and she'd and every time i would tell
her hey mom i switched my name i'm under
this and she'd be
and she'd be so bummed why don't
why tom tom do we have to do it like
this because
i don't like this peter goes in your
stuff
i don't like you know like just like she
would hate it but
and i would do it almost just to make
her [ __ ] crazy she's like oh god
i have to ask for [ __ ] this person
like i'm just always bummed around i i
gotta ask and we can cut this out
but was she bummed on the sex tape that
came out
she she was like she was [ __ ] really
tripping she was bummed like she was mad
she was like i can't believe
and she understood it was just like a
you know
me and my wife at the time on vacation
doing the same [ __ ] that
y'all would do with your chicks right
wow yeah
she was just like i can't believe
someone stole that
you know out of your house and now it's
on the [ __ ] news
you know that's that's what made
uh her upset more than anything she just
couldn't believe that
but you're like dude mom it's cool i got
the hugest dong
well this is it's not a bad thing mom
it's cool
i mean dude we actually surveyed a
hundred people
asking them like to name a celebrity
with a huge [ __ ]
and a hundred percent of them said
yeah that's awesome all one hundred
that's [ __ ] steering the boat with
your dog
you are the poster child for having
that's [ __ ] crazy
i mean who else is known for having a
big dong uh
what tommy lee
right name what's his name the [ __ ]
oh
peter north right right but he's a porn
star that doesn't count
oh yeah that he doesn't i don't i mean
who who's had a sex tape you've had a
sex tape
leaked out but no no no no
you know we did the photo shoot at
hollywood science right right right
right
i got i got to share though with you
guys and the listeners
you know anybody who's trying to impress
somebody
uh female or male whatever you think
whatever you're into
um i asked him i'm like dude
i asked peter north i'm like he's at my
house we're having a party and they're
wrangling dude
how the [ __ ] do you when you [ __ ]
come do you hit the front of this truck
from here
like how is that possible he goes
i'll tell you my secret i go i go
all right he goes the night before he
[ __ ]
he ground he sticks in a blender two but
two bushels like the whole thing of
celery
and the fiber in the celery [ __ ]
and and all the liquid in the celery
make you [ __ ]
uh have that much ropes that much
jizz and then he goes what i'll do is
i'll also drink about a gallon
of um pineapple juice because that makes
your [ __ ] [ __ ] taste sweet
and i was like thanks for the advice
and it [ __ ] works the celery dude the
celery and pineapple juice
works everybody's buying celery right
now yeah
amazon prime people got tape measures
out dude i shot it [ __ ]
four foot six bro i mean dude when i
have the pineapple juice
there's no measuring because it's going
right in my mouth
[Laughter]
that's awesome yeah some girl told me
she's like i don't trust a man who
hasn't tasted his own [ __ ]
i've never tasted it i've never tasted
my own coffee either not even a little
tommy house
i had a mental block against that dude
yeah i can't wrap my head around it but
it's
salty wasn't it didn't you do some
[ __ ] up
yeah somebody jerk off into a [ __ ]
condom yeah i did dude i did swallow
pontius has come yes that's yeah that
finally came out i got it live on my
website dude i got that whole
[ __ ] crazy special is it is it
visible
yeah i have to see that i did it's
[ __ ] it's a good
time good times it's a good time now
like
that's gnarly you party dude yeah i
wonder how he would have
kept up with you guys if you guys were
drinking all together could you imagine
if he was in motley crue like and
you know he was i don't know like a
[ __ ] percussion yeah i'd be like your
flavor flavor
just give him the cowbell the hype man
i don't think i would have done too well
dude i i would i would have
probably done just as many as much drugs
as everybody oh yeah i just wasn't fun
to be around
you know i i'm not good with with all
that
but uh you know it's it's rad too that
um
you know like the with the the jail and
i know i know you had some [ __ ]
crazy lawsuits and [ __ ] too because you
haven't had like
real like turbulence and you're like the
shit's pretty smooth sailing for you huh
for a while now yeah it's been nice
right you have to [ __ ] admit it dude
has been really nice i mean like we were
talking the other night there was uh
before the movie came out
and and and of course the the director
of the dirt on netflix
is the same director of jackass yeah so
like we're all in the same kind of
family
and uh and when you were on the there
was some like thing with like uh
you know like your son and you guys got
in kind of a fight
it was all on tmz jeff tremaine was
thrilled with the publicity he's like
yeah i'm [ __ ] right on tommy keep the
news coming man
keep things coming but that's like the
only thing that's yeah
like you've been you know like switch
rad man it's rad that uh
you know unlike some other people we
were talking about the other night
who seemed to be in trouble a lot all
the time
yeah the things with my son are great he
was actually you just missed him
he was just here um uh
grabbing the uh the golf cart to go down
and play at the country club here and
that's just really good with my son and
i like it i don't know it was just like
that you know it was like the there was
a lot going on around that time and it
was just sort of
you know it needed i don't say need
it needed to happen but i don't know it
just was one of those things you know
button heads and yeah and uh
brought you closer after i get way
closer and i've been i've done the same
thing with my dad
yeah i [ __ ] i thought i was all
badass and punched my dad same thing
yeah you know all i don't know if all
dudes do it but i did it with my brother
me and my brother i i finally just
socked him in the face and said [ __ ] and
then we've never been closer ever since
then
right something that was on the news
and it's just so [ __ ] weird the
rapper guy copying your drum roll roller
coaster
like yeah identical
yeah this was the final tour that motley
crew had right
and and you know it was called the final
tour yep
um they [ __ ]
tommy lee's drum solo for this one is
just a full-on roller coaster that just
goes throughout the whole arena
yep and and then next thing you know
this rapper guy travis scott
like he didn't even try to make it
slightly different it's exactly
the same thing they just took the drums
off and put like a different
like a rollerco like a roller coaster
cart yeah that seats one or two people
in it and it was actually the same
physical all the same parts it's from
the same company oh
wow he just went and got it from the
company that built it for you
and not and not one but two remember
when i did the i don't know if you
remember but
i did the 360 was just the big the big
loop
uh he got stuck on it same thing he
he went and got that one and it's just
one seat with him in the chair rapping
going upside
up you know going around in a loop and
i'm like weird dude get your own [ __ ]
bro
yeah well and rapping upside down is not
as hard as drumming upside
down yeah i mean yeah basically
yeah talking upside down i guess you
gotta just be
be stoked on the flattery yeah like
that's cool i you know that part's cool
i mean
at the same time imitation is suicide
you know it's like yeah
get your own [ __ ] right dude and so now
you're
you've got uh [ __ ]
i mean we didn't bring up the djing dude
you've been djing
for how long dude [ __ ] like
jesus christ when when we got together
in 2003
yeah but i was doing it like in you were
already [ __ ] on fire doing it
98 99
yeah yeah so you're a bonafide [ __ ]
i love that bonafide dj you had methods
of mayhem you had like oh you've had
various music
projects but right now you can order
your new album
yeah yeah dude andro it comes out uh
you can pre-order it it comes out [ __ ]
uh
i always get this [ __ ] wrong october
14th i think yeah yeah man
and you've already got some singles out
yep yep there's two singles that just
came out
and then an uh like a new new one that
just came out a [ __ ] week ago
um with uh tyla and uh post malone
yeah and it's just a song called [ __ ]
tommy lee dude it's
[ __ ] so rad they named you [ __ ]
named a song after me they're like dude
with the song with the song uh called
tommy lee out
uh then we would you would you do a
remix and i was like [ __ ] yeah and so
it's so
cool like so yeah anyway that's how too
and and it's it's mostly like
electronic music um no the
oh my record yeah uh no it's all over
the place there's some [ __ ]
there's some [ __ ] super hard
uh you know uh electro
there's some [ __ ] screamo metal
there's some [ __ ] edm sound and stuff
there's some rock [ __ ] there is you know
me dude like
yeah with any anything i do i'm like
genre wise there's no lines i just
i [ __ ] with all of it i love it so yeah
the record's really cool um
and i think the cool thing the reason
it's called andro short for
androgyny is that is somehow i ended up
with
[ __ ] seven or eight uh six or seven
tracks with
all male energy and six or seven with
all female energy and i
kept trying to [ __ ] sequence the
record like i wanted to play like this
and then i want this track to go next
and what the
and it just wasn't [ __ ] working and
finally i just separated them like old
school
wise and i went in on my head and went
why don't i just give them their own
side you know put all the [ __ ] boys
here and put all the
the girls on the other side and dude and
that would and what didn't really plan
that i didn't plan to have
that many there were that amount of
different collaborations
but it just worked out that way and
coming to that realization
of splitting them is when i decided to
call andrew i was like
this is [ __ ] cool man this record's
got a a a really heavy
male and female uh energy presence
so uh i hope everyone digs it it's a
[ __ ] rad record
cool yeah dope i remember getting an
advanced copy
of uh yeah i'll send it to you soon yeah
dude
what was the one uh it came out like
right like 2010
like uh when we were doing jackass 3d i
feel like you had an
album come out and i don't know if that
was methods of mayhem i think it was uh
it was just my own stuff yeah was that
the was it called a public disservice
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that i recorded
that record
i did here in my house but i the cool
thing about that record is i recorded
that
uh with the whole world
like i i went online and i would put up
the base
track the drum track uh
a guitar or a guitar track three tracks
maybe four
and i'd be like here you guys have at it
just put it out on the [ __ ] internet
and dude we would get submissions from
all around the world
would take days to go through these and
we'd be like oh
that's a [ __ ] gem and we literally
um got people submitted parts from also
i basically made a record with the world
wow it was so [ __ ] rad and i
and and it would be impossible to go and
like
um uh you know publishing wise to go and
give
every single person credit so uh
in return my credit was you know i'm you
know
you'll get uh you know a visual
credit on the record like your part who
you are what you did
you know so and that would be the only
way to kind of keep track but otherwise
it'd be a [ __ ] nightmare it'd be like
accounting would be very complicated
licensing hell like dude how did we do
this
so that was uh in return but uh so
you know you got you saw your name and
what part you played but
that was a fun process but i'll never do
it again because i had no idea was that
i mean we would we'd spend [ __ ] hours
and days just going through
a lot of shitty parts being something
right like dude what do you think of my
drone partner mike
right i don't know dude right yeah but
it was fun it was a cool record
that's cool and uh so molly crew
uh you know we just said before those
the final tour
was in 2015. and then and you guys had
like this contract
we're not gonna tour anymore yeah and
then he blew up the contract which was
kind of genius and jeff tremaine was
behind that too
yeah so but like i i
i totally defend motley crew and the
decision to blow up that contract and
and it's really clear why because
everything that made you guys want to
say this is our final tour we're not
going to do it we're not going to be
like the [ __ ] eagles with hell froze
over
you know the difference is that all
those bands that said they were on their
final tour
then all of a sudden like they they
needed to
[ __ ] put it back together it was like
a move of desperation
yes when in fact for motley crue or i've
done it
several times you're like dude what what
number of farewell tour are you guys on
right right kiss is famous for that sure
dude
yeah farewell was how many tours ago
right yeah and then uh baby you guys had
the netflix movie come out
and it was just like all right now we've
got like you said
young people who say [ __ ] man i wish i
was there when all this was going i've
got a whole new
yeah a whole new generation of young
fans that are just [ __ ] hungry for
motley crue and so you said you know
what
it's not because we're desperate we
don't need to [ __ ] do it we're
[ __ ] fine
but we're there's just so much demand
we're just going to [ __ ] do it
blow up the contract so crazy so you
guys put together this stadium tour with
[ __ ] motley crue def leppard poison
joan jett and the whole [ __ ]
it's not arenas this is state stadium
and like and dude i'm following you on
social media and i see
i see like oh hey man like we added some
shows and so you [ __ ] put these
schedules and it's just like the whole
[ __ ] schedule
sold out sold out sold out the added
show like [ __ ] sold out sold out like
i'm like damn these [ __ ] guys are
just sold out like
way in advance they sold out a whole
stadium tour
and then [ __ ] coronavirus pogba i
know
dude when was the tour supposed to
happen it was supposed to start in
september yeah like next month
yeah [ __ ] no sorry no it's supposed to
start um
june 17th june 17th was the date
it was supposed to be so many cities so
i would have been on tour right now
still
it didn't end until it was supposed to
end september oh yeah it was going to be
the final show was gonna be in l.a
something like that in september
september 5th at because i know this one
for a fact
because it's what's in the new [ __ ]
rams
yeah oh yeah
so five stadiums yeah you see it as you
land into lax dude it's [ __ ]
jetsons bro i'm so excited to play there
um i told eric andre on the podcast next
year
yeah i told eric andre that i think
that it's him with his movie getting
shelved a week before it was supposed to
come out in theaters
and motley crew with this sold out
stadium tour
the people who got [ __ ] screwed over
by coronavirus the worst
oh man and he's like yeah well some
people did die yeah
there's people on ventilators right now
i know that's just
that's the sad part i know dude but
still man that [ __ ]
that's that stings man i saw nikki
tweeted like yesterday only 325 days
until the [ __ ]
yeah a little early bro yeah
so the stadium tour has been rescheduled
and it's just
fingers crossed so like all the tickets
everything that was good then it just
literally got
moved exactly a year right when you
start working out for that
i'll start we go out when in june i'll
start like
[ __ ] april because you got to get your
arms and then yeah
cardio [ __ ] playing every day so a
couple months before that yeah
i was interested i'm sorry to cut you
off but uh
he he checked his pedometer tommy did
and he does like 13 miles per show
is what he's oh yeah yeah how do you
that's funny you know that
yeah i went deep dude yeah i was just
curious i'm like [ __ ] man
i i've weighed the same since i've been
in [ __ ] high school
literally the same and i'm like how much
uh i weigh 170.
oh okay me too really today i'm 172.00
i was just [ __ ] curious i'm like how
come you know it's probably because i
sweat like a [ __ ] every night
um so i'm just curious you know i wonder
what
what this equates to what kind of
exercise so i grabbed one of those
pedometer things
and i just [ __ ] clicked it on the
inside of my high top
and after a two-hour show i [ __ ] took
it off and it said 12.3 miles i was like
damn every night every night i was like
no wonder i can't gain any [ __ ]
weight yeah
between that and the [ __ ] drugs and
[ __ ] dudes
you think you'd be able to i don't know
yeah
he's crazy what's it uh what's the
longest you've lived on a tour bus
oh whoa
[ __ ] that's hard to estimate because you
you do your legs right is it like just a
couple months yeah but you'll see six
weeks on six weeks off
yeah that sounds like about right and or
then you're moving it to canada
so you're off the bus for a minute and
now you're going on different buses or
uh you know it does have little little
pockets but [ __ ] it's
it's like a [ __ ] it's not it's not
like um
i went on a tour of uh a submarine
once and the guys were giving me the
tour and like and i was like how long do
these guys stay down here they're like
sometimes they live down here underwater
under
the bottom of the ocean in the submarine
for up to six months they don't see it
i'm never going to complain about the
tour bus ever and these [ __ ]
don't see
daylight for six months or other people
just them the stadium tour was was
booked for outside the states is
uh that that was going to be next like
that was
like as you know that's what uh
promoters were working on
once we did the as we were doing the
states dates
we're going to move it over either to
canada europe
we were trying to figure out what was
next because of the success of it we're
like
[ __ ] let's just let's take this
[ __ ] around
yeah you know i'm always so interested
with like touring because
uh you know i helped set steve up with
his comedy tour and stuff
i'm always so fascinated with people's
writers what was on your rider for the
girls girls girls tour
do you did you have anything specific or
is it just whatever or
is there things that you like well
definitely the there was a
pretty strict booze rider there was
always jack
always beers um uh
wine alcohol yeah just pretty much all
booze
i think oh yeah like you know but
nothing's like
nothing like you hear about brown
eminem's or you know
yeah that was special requests we just
had like kind of the lame like
[ __ ] deli tray you know meat and
cheese things and some cut up fruit
oh peanut butter was a good one because
that had multiple purposes
and [ __ ] and and uh and some [ __ ]
mayo and
mustard that's pretty much it like
there's no like
special requests i'm just always so
fascinating because
some guys want like a new pair of shoes
every set they do or
oh yeah you know there is yeah um
socks were a big one for us socks and
underwear are always good
yeah just like you know what there's
nothing better than putting on a brand
new pair of socks you're like oh
back in the day we would have socks
underwear and we would make the
the [ __ ] promoter supplies with our
mini dv
tapes because we were always filming oh
yeah yeah so we'd have to
just supply us with videotapes because
we never stopped shooting
not smart yeah dude well [ __ ] hey man
i did i'm just so
i'm so stoked that we we got to do this
man yes
what a bro [ __ ] tommy lee man i just
i want to put it out there that
that uh since 1987
dude you have been nothing but [ __ ]
good to me dude
i love you brother dude
yeah dude i appreciate you so so much
and uh let's let's sell some [ __ ]
some andro records dude yeah i loved
your website because i when i was
scrolling through it i went to the
bottom it was like take me to the top
and i clicked it i was like who did this
dude this is
sick jj is my web guy
amazing tommy's always
thanks for having me thank you man yeah
it was great yeah thank you tommy
yes thank you guys man oh come on
that was insane thank you
tommy lee and thank you you beautiful
people who hung in there until the very
end
i call you my street team and that's
because i love the way that you've
helped me get the word out there about
this podcast
by taking a screenshot of the podcast
which i'm asking you to do for this one
man you take the screenshot of the
podcast you post it
with me tagged with tommy lee tagged
just to tell him how much you enjoyed
that
and uh dude i just appreciate you guys
man
and especially the people who have
watched my gnarly comedy special
ah the big stunt hasn't happened yet huh
no
no but oh something big is gonna happen
it's wild right baby come on